>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Katie Alvarez:
Hello everyone.
Can you hear me?
So, we're going to start
the last session a few
minutes early.
Maybe we'll get out of
here a few minutes early.
We'll see.
So, welcome to the
concluding session called
"Where do We Go from Here?"
I'm Katie Alvarez.
I'm an attorney with the
Copyright Office, and --
>> Matthew Barblan: I'm
Matthew Barblan, the Director
for the Center for
the Protection
of Intellectual Property
at Mason Law.
>> Katie Alvarez: And
so, as you can see,
this panel is a little
different.
We're the two moderators and
you guys are all the panelists.
So, Register Pallante
had mentioned earlier
that moral rights aren't
really talked about that much
in the United States and
that today's symposium is the
starting point of
that conversation.
So, now that you've
had a whole eight hours
to digest everything, we
want to turn it over to you
and hear what you think.
So, what's next for
moral rights?
Kind of some questions that
I had come up with: So,
is the status quo good enough?
Do we need some changes?
Is that change legislative?
Is there room for any voluntary
or non-legislative initiatives?
Also, are there any
issues that came up today
that are especially important
to you or issues that came
up that sort of raised
more questions
since we covered a lot?
So, then to start off this
conversation, Matt is going
to go through a few highlights
from today's symposium.
>> Matthew Barblan: Yeah.
So, before we open up
the open mic session,
I think it's helpful just to go
over a couple of the highlights,
some of the things
that stuck with me
from today's session just
to jog people's memories
and to give you some
ideas for comments
and for your thoughts
on these issues.
So before I start that, I just
want to say that, you know,
the things that I mention
are neither exhaustive nor
particularly well curated.
They just happen to be the
things that stuck out to me,
and I hope that talking
through some of the comments
that were made and the ideas
that were raised will help all
of you think of your comments
for what we should do
going forward or, you know,
any thoughts or complaints about
things that were said today and,
of course, your helpful advice
about what the Copyright
Office should do
in the moral rights space.
So, we heard from a wide
variety of viewpoints today.
We kicked it off early on.
We heard that moral rights
are like the Zika virus.
Ideally we would eradicate them
completely but, at a minimum,
we should keep them
outside the U.S. [laughter].
We also heard about some of
the philosophical difficulties
of wedging moral rights into
the United States' dynamic view
of property that has
historically favored
unencumbered and freely
alienable economic rights
but about how despite
that difficulty,
there still is a space for
moral rights in American law.
We heard from artists
about the difficulty
in separating the
economic from the moral.
Attribution can be key to the
development of an artist's brand
and it's something that can help
artists put food on the table,
and a great example
to take away there is
that if you write a song
about getting stoned,
you don't want people to think
that it was a Tom Petty
song about getting stoned.
We heard about how we
might convince France
to bring a WTO action against
the U.S. for failure to comply
with Berne's Article
10, permission to quote.
We learned about the maximal
monkey agency approach
to authorship and how if we
are going to have a right
of attribution, the importance
of having a solid understanding
of who the author really is and
who we're going to attribute to.
We talked about how the Dastar
case took away an already barely
plausible argument we had
that we were in compliance
with Berne's moral
rights requirements,
and we discussed whether
acknowledging moral rights would
break the internet, and kind
of the take-away there
was David Lowery's quote:
"If the internet is the
most amazing thing ever,
it should be able to withstand
artists asserting their
moral rights."
We talked about the
connection between moral rights
and the incentive not just
to create copyrighted works,
but also the incentive
to publish
and disseminate those works
so that other people
can have access to them,
whether for free or by paying.
We talked about, you
know, things that can step
in to fulfill the role of
moral rights in the absence
of an actual moral
rights regime --
things like collective
bargaining and contract law.
And then the last thing I'll
leave you with before we open
up the floor to comments
and thoughts is we learned
about why the most common artist
on Sirius radio is
various artists
and how a robust moral rights
regime could change that.
So, with those thoughts
in your mind,
we'd love to just get ideas from
people in the audience about,
you know, steps that
can be taken,
avenues that could
be researched,
or things that the Copyright
Office could do to, you know,
delve deeper into the
moral rights space.
>> Katie Alvarez: And also
I know we didn't have a lot
of room for questions
and answers during
the other sessions.
So, if someone has something
that they wanted to bring
up earlier and didn't get a
chance, now is your chance.
>> Matthew Barblan: And
if nobody has thoughts,
I'm happy to call on
people [laughter].
>> Unidentified Female
Speaker: Hi.
So, I kind of come from the
perspective of the artist
and talking to artists
about what they know
about their rights.
And what's interesting to me
and kind of stuck out to me was
when Professor Ginsburg
said that most people think
that they have the
right of attribution
when they really don't.
I would say that most artists --
they get told, "Oh I don't have
to respect your copyrights
because I gave you attribution."
And so artists are
extremely confused.
They think, "Oh, do they just
need to give me attribution
or do I still have a
right if they use my image
in a way I didn't
want to use it" --
which says to me that there
is a big need for education
in this field as well.
>> Matthew Barblan: Yeah,
I think that's right.
I think education is
key, and the confusion
that can easily develop
among the people that stand
to benefit both from copyright
and from moral rights is
something that persists;
and at a minimum, even if we're
not going to make any changes
to the law, it's helpful
if people understand what
their actual rights are.
>> Matthew Barblan: Alright.
Sandra?
>> Sandra Aistars: So, I thought
I'd maybe make a quick comment
about one theme that
has kept coming up
and that is what's the public's
benefit from moral rights?
And as I listened to
people answer the question
over the course of the day, a
couple of thoughts came to mind.
First, I think if you think
about what the public's
benefit might be, an easy answer
to that is the truth, right?
We get to know whose work it
actually is and how to access
that person if we want to
interact with him or her either
in the capacity of a fan --
you know, buying tickets to
David Lowery's show rather
than Tom Petty's show -- or,
you know, in the capacity
of a potential licensor
of the work.
But one thing that I
kept having in the back
of my mind is a conversation
that my clinic students
and I had with photojournalist
Yunghi Kim.
She's a Pulitzer Prize
finalist and war zone,
conflict zone journalist.
And this was in the context
of comments we were submitting
to the Section 512 study, but
what she told us was that one
of the things that is
most troubling to her
when infringements
of her works occur is
that the work is
often misrepresented
for something that it is not.
So, for instance, she has a
very famous image of a young boy
in Kosovo and that image has
been taken by various, you know,
either revolutionary
groups or other groups
and represented as
something else.
One instance it was represented
to be a Palestinian boy
rather than, you know,
accurately reflecting, you
know, the truth of the matter.
You hear about these stories
also in other contexts.
I mean when Boko Haram
kidnapped the girls in Nigeria,
the first thing that popped
up on Facebook was an image
of a completely different group
of girls that was, you know,
used to represent these, you
know, Nigerian kidnapees.
I think the public loses
something if you can't rely
on a photojournalist's image
actually being what it purports
to be.
And to me, I wonder, you know,
which of these rights
really addresses this.
To some degree I think it's an
integrity issue; but, you know,
the image isn't necessarily
altered.
I guess it's, you know,
put in a different context.
You know, I'm not sure that the
attribution issue helps us any
because just the fact that,
you know, it's attributed
to Yunghi Kim doesn't resolve
the fact that the work is,
you know, being represented
in a way that's inaccurate
to her subjects.
So, I'm curious whether
others have, you know,
thoughts on how this
might be addressed
and whether that's
something that is already kind
of within the sphere
of what we're talking
about in terms of moral rights.
>> Matthew Barblan: And
I'd add that that ties back
into the point that Professor
Ginsburg was making in response
to one of her questions that,
you know, when you're trying
to justify potential
legislative or other action
in the moral rights space, you
know, it's not just the fact
that we arguably
aren't in compliance
with the Berne Convention,
but also that there is a
legitimate public interest,
at least there are many
arguments you can make
for public interest.
>> Unidentified Female
Speaker 1: I'll speak to that
in the context of
writers and in terms
of the rights of attribution.
This is something that I have
been aware of during the course
of time that I have
been a writer,
and it addresses the notion
of ghostwriting and people
who write with other people.
And I remember 25 or 30 years
ago you would see a celebrity
biography and it would
say, "as told to".
It was Rin Tin Tin "as
told to David Johnson".
So, you knew it was not
told by Rin Tin Tin;
it was actually written
by David Johnson.
Then that became blurred, and
now the celebrity biographies
or memoirs or autobiographies
all say "by Elizabeth Taylor".
And, again, if we're talking
about giving the public
the truth, everyone knows
that this celebrity
didn't write the book.
That's public knowledge.
And yet the book is published
under that person's name.
So, the ghostwriter has lost all
professional sense, no ownership
of the work, no moral
right to attribution.
And I know of one person who
wrote a celebrity biography
and he told me -- Every time
I would see him I would say,
"How's it going?"
And he'd say, "It's great."
And I said, "Where's
your name going to be?"
And he'd say, "On the
front of the book.
It's going to be a
joint biography."
It came out without
his name anywhere
and it just gradually --
sort of the tide receded,
and he just didn't get it.
And I know of another one
in which the writer died
just before the publication,
and with only the
widow to protest,
they just took his
name off it altogether.
So, the public loses there
in terms of this sense
of truthfulness and
authenticity,
and why should we
be party to a system
that just withdraws the sense
of truth from the public?
>> Unidentified Female Speaker
2: And just to add something
to the public benefit of
the right of attribution,
it has been the common practice
in the publishing industry
to provide attribution except
for these ghostwritten books,
which is slowly changing, but
most authors write in part
for the right of attribution.
I think if we were to survey
our members they would say
that they probably wouldn't
have gone into writing
if they hadn't thought
that their work could
be attributed to them.
Now mid-list writers
are having a harder
and harder time economically,
and there are just fewer
books being published
on serious subjects
for mid-list authors.
So, many of our members,
particularly members
that have written many books
in their 50's and 60's,
are starting to write books
without their name
being put on the book.
You know, often they're
rich people
who just want a book
written by somebody
and they want their name on the
book, not the actual author's.
And, yes, you will find
authors willing to do this
because they need
to pay the mortgage;
or in many cases I have friends
who say they're doing this
because they, you know, well
their kids are in college
and "then I'm going back
to writing my own stuff."
So, I think an important thing
to remember is it's
also an incentive.
That's my point.
It's as much of an incentive
as the copyright right.
>> Eugene Mopsik:
I think frequently,
at least for many commercial
artists, we lose sight
of what the end game is in
all of these discussions;
and for me as a commercial
artist, copyright
and moral rights ultimately
are I guess a means to allow me
to continue to profit and to
profit from my creative works.
And so they're a means to an
end and they're not the end,
and I think in that direction
we need to support efforts to --
as Nancy spoke about
persistent identifiers,
and it gets even
more cumbersome.
It's more like machine-readable
persistent identifiers.
So, there are identifiers that
are persistent and can work
in the background and don't
require human intervention
to enforce rights and
ultimately are able to manage,
or at least visual artists
would be able to manage a lot
of these downstream uses that
we were talking about today --
the secondary uses of images,
where right now it's
the total Wild West
and photographs are just
being used willy-nilly.
So --
>> Unidentified Male
Speaker: Looking at it
from a slightly different
point of view, I'm a litigator
and I do this from a more
practical point of view
than the esoteric; and
when you have people having
misattribution or
nonattribution, Dastar killed us
on one whole good
creative set of arguments.
But one of the other problems
you have is the preemption.
Like when I try to file,
or if I'm the defendant --
I'm like 12(b)(6) -- when people
try to use unfair competition
or other kinds of things, I
say, "Hey, it's preempted" or,
you know, it's a problem I
have if I want to plead it
because this is all subject
of the Copyright Act,
and it is not included.
So, the various different
kind of creative elements
or arguments that one might
make I'm not real sure that,
because of the preemption,
that they would get very far.
So, just a practical
thing there.
>> Matthew Barblan:
Someone in the back.
>> Mira Sundara Rajan: Hi.
My name is Mira Sundara Rajan.
I'm a professor of
Intellectual Property Law
at the CREATe Copyright
Center in the U.K.
and I've written a not
insubstantial book entitled
Moral Rights: Principles,
Practice and New Technology --
for that reason I have
a number of thoughts
but at least a couple of
which I'd like to share
in the limited time
that we have available.
One of them is that I've been
listening with a lot of interest
to these comments about
what is the public interest
in moral rights, an issue I talk
quite a bit about in my book,
and I think it's a key question
that we need to be
able to answer.
You know, we heard
from the authors.
We know how they feel about it.
We know to some extent how
our middle men feel about it.
How does the public
feel about it?
And for me the important point
that we need to remember is
that all works eventually
end up being owned
in a sense by the public.
They go into the public
domain, all copyright works,
and that idea was
expressed by Victor Hugo,
who said that the true heir
of any writer is ultimately
going to be the public.
And I think when we think about
the issue of moral rights,
it's helpful to keep
that in mind,
that preserving the
attribution of works,
preserving historical truth,
preserving the integrity
of works that are in the
cultural domain is something
that ultimately is a
matter of importance
for every citizen of a country.
Another issue here that
may be apt as well is
that American artists
are in a curious position
because when you go out of
the country with your work --
Let's say you go to France --
your moral rights
are recognized.
And yet here in the
United States at home,
you don't have the same rights
that you enjoy in
foreign countries.
And I'm Canadian; we
have moral rights.
If I were an American creator,
I think I'd be quite upset
about that situation.
So, I do think that there
is some national pride,
cultural pride involved.
And maybe that goes to a
final interesting point,
which is what we're talking
about here is cultural
diversity.
Well, let's not forget that
cultural diversity also exists
in the law and that has been
maybe an interesting backhanded
development as far as
the relative exclusion
of moral rights from
TRIPS' concern
because countries have
adopted moral rights in keeping
with Berne and TRIPS, but
there is tremendous diversity
in how different countries
have implemented moral rights.
I mean literally it would be
difficult to find two countries
that have done it the same
way, and you have everything
from the U.K. situation, where
you have to assert your right
of attribution before you can
expect to have it recognized,
to the situation in
India, where rights
of integrity are
protected forever.
Why are they protected forever?
Well, the Indian
copyright registrar told me
that amendment was brought
in for a specific reason --
because the interest of the
public in the preservation
of the cultural domain was
considered to be so important
that integrity had to be
legislated for time immemorial.
So, you have so many
different approaches,
and I think that at least
should be very encouraging here
in the United States because
there's so much that can be done
to recognize moral rights
and yet to give them a shape
that makes sense in the
cultural, technological, social,
economic context
here in the states.
>> Matthew Barblan: Thank you.
And can you remind us of
the title of your book?
>> An easy question to answer.
It's called Moral
Rights [laughter],
the key words being new
technology, and it's published
by Oxford University
Press, just about to come
out in a second edition.
So, please don't try to buy it
until a few more
months go by [laughter].
>> Matthew Barblan: Any more
comments or suggestions?
>> Katie Alvarez: We have one
hiding behind the pillar here.
>> Matthew Barblan:
Oh, excellent.
>> Unidentified Female Speaker
3: I just wanted to speak
to a form of expression
that I hope becomes part
of the conversation moving
forward and that's dance.
I think the absence of that
in the conversation
today is probably --
it's illustrative of the sort of
lesser degree of pervasiveness
in culture than something
like music or books,
but that was I think largely an
accessibility issue in the past.
And with, you know, an increased
focus on digitized entertainment
and technology and with
content hosting sites,
I think dance finally has the
means and window of opportunity
to be able to reach
a broader audience
and disseminate their
work on a greater scale.
In terms of protecting the
rights of sound recordings
and musicians and performers,
I'm hoping that dance
will be a consideration
so that they can take advantage
of this opportunity and finally,
you know, have their moment
and push their way into society
and culture and become
more pervasive.
>> Matthew Barblan: And
Brad, we have a question
over here on the left.
>> Unidentified Male
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Just one or two quick thoughts.
One is that the discussion
has talked
about incentives a good bit and
interests of various groups,
public or other maybe.
But the term itself,
moral rights, you know,
both of those words are very
interesting and useful, too;
and I think, you know,
going forward fuller use
could be given to both
of those terms and, you know,
I think of the, you know,
sort of historic American
principle in American law
that rights are not
only something
that government would give or
take away on a whim or based
on a particular interest, but
that there are certain rights
that -- and here I think there
was the quote earlier on about,
you know, a person
being entitled
to the fruits of their labor.
So, I don't recall
exactly the quote.
But the other point that
I was going to raise was
that law can have a teaching
function also so that even
if there's not a very elaborate
complicated system that is put
in place right away,
giving some protection
to moral rights can
help to remind people
that this is something that
is something to be valued,
you know, because
I think so often
if the law doesn't require
something, they'll you know,
give a copyright
notice or something
but they won't give
recognition to the authors
because there's no feeling
that they should do so.
>> Matthew Barblan: Thank you.
>> Katie Alvarez: Anyone else?
>> Matthew Barblan: Ah,
you got one in the back.
>> Katie Alvarez:
One in the back.
>> Melvin Gibbs: It's more
of a comment than a question.
I was just thinking about the
two panels ago contrasting the
public art, the mural, and
the relationship of public art
to moral rights as opposed
to the relationship
to the digital arts.
I was thinking that in
terms of my own comments
about how moral rights relate
to communities and I thought
that was a very interesting
illustration of the difference
between when you have something
that's based in the community
and how people relate
to the rights as opposed
to when it's just
floating around digitally.
And it's interesting that dance
was brought up because dance is
in a sort of middle
position right now --
well, talking about
street dance in particular,
which is one area
I'm interested in.
It's still a community
but it's kind
of like a worldwide
community and attribution --
everybody kind of knows
who's making up the steps
because they're getting
uploaded so quickly
but they're also getting
disseminated very quickly
at the same time.
So, I'm wondering -- it seems
like maybe that's an actual
beginnings of solution
of crossing those things --
looking at dance might be a way
to kind of think through
an actual solution there.
>> Karyn Temple Claggett:
Any last minute thoughts,
comments, questions?
>> Matthew Barblan: We have
two more -- Alan and Mary.
>> Mary Rasenberger: I have
a question for everybody here
and that is after seeing
Scott Martin's presentation
on the different laws
around the world --
At lunch we were
talking about, you know,
need for unification of IT laws.
Is there any interest
in an international
treaty on moral rights?
[inaudible]
>> Karyn Temple Claggett:
Other than the one we already
actually have [laughter].
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
>> Matthew Barblan: Allan?
>> Allan Adler: This is a
question I probably should have
asked to session five when they
were up there, but it occurred
to me one of the
major developments,
at least for my industry, since
moral rights was the source
of major discussion here in
the United States is the fact
that the internet has given rise
to a new generation
of self-publication.
And I'm just wondering
in that environment
where the author essentially
also becomes the publisher
and the person chiefly
responsible for distribution
of their own work, if that makes
a difference in the calculations
that people would make about --
Well, certainly I think it would
with respect to integrity
issues but I'm wondering
if it would also make a
difference with respect
to attribution issues as well.
>> Karyn Temple Claggett:
And the last comment?
>> Unidentified Female
Speaker 4: Good afternoon.
It's not comments,
just an inquiry.
I'm not a lawyer.
I came to attend this
symposium; it's a course for me.
So, I was reading each
speech for moral view.
So, I have a question.
I was trained as a biologist.
So, in the international
collaborations I see some lack
or gap between the
piracy and the law.
So, here we talk all day
about law, copyrights law,
moral rights law, attribution.
But how about piracy?
Here I would like to
present to you a scenario
from the U.S. Office
of Research Integrity.
I would learn a few months ago
in this office there's a policy
of plagiarism, if put in this
room would be plagiarism,
but there they didn't
see it as plagiarism,
but authorship dispute.
They say that the ORI, the
Office of Research Integrity,
considers many disputes
between the collaborators
on the same research project
as an authorship dispute
or credit disputes
rather than plagiarism.
So, I would ask your insights.
How could make the interaction
between policy and the law?
Thank you.
>> Karyn Temple Claggett:
I don't think we're going
to answer that question today.
>> Matthew Barblan: But thanks
for raising it [laughter].
>> Thank you.
I want to thank the panelists
from the last panel
and the audience.
I also want to thank all
of the panelists who've
been here throughout the day
as well as the audience.
I think, as I said, when I first
started the overview session I
didn't know whether we would
actually have enough to discuss
for a full day of moral
rights in the United States,
but it not only showed that we
actually have a lot to discuss
but a lot of important
information
and it really showed how
strongly people believe
that especially the moral rights
of attribution and integrity are
to individual authors.
So, you've given us
a lot to think about.
As I think Register Pallante
mentioned at the beginning
of the day, this is only the
beginning of our conversation.
We'll now take some
of the things
that you guys have
said today and use
that to actually ask more
specific questions in terms
of what should we do next
as we analyze moral rights
in the United States
and we consider how best do we
actually protect both individual
authors as well as the public
in terms of wanting to know
who creates the work and
how the work is being used.
So, thank you again
for participating
and thank you all for coming.
>> Matthew Barblan:
Thanks Karyn.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.